let's say there was a fire and you had
to choose between saving your own child
which I doubt you have but let's pretend
that you do and saving a black child
that's not yours which one would you say
well first off you know what they say
about assumptions makes an ass out of
you yeah me but in this case just you
because I would save the black child
first
welcome to devil's advocate I'm your
host Skyler Jordan today we'll be
talking with a guest about a hot topic
of abortion before I came on the show
actually had um some trail mix and I
don't know if I've caught my tooth visit
Kashi there's like a like a filbert
not sure but she brought me the chef a
warning on those on those packages it's
gonna stay with me all day
all right so our guest to talk about
this issue I guess you've seen as an
authoritative figure on the right as it
relates to the topic of abortion she
released a film that I believe she she
produced directed starred in as well
unplanned film.com former director of
Planned Parenthood a while back avi
Johnson thanks for being with us thank
you so much Skyler so Allah sure that
people understand this you talk about
abortion quite a bit you consider
yourself I don't want to mislabel you
pro-life anti-choice one of them
definitely for choices so I'm not anti
choice yeah point life okay so you're
not anti choice so you support a woman's
right to choose them yeah I definitely
support a woman's right to make choices
with pregnancy as long as that choice
isn't infringe on the rights of another
human being right until you would
support her choice to a terminate a
pregnancy if need be I know
because that choice would then infringe
upon the rights of another huge be paws
up
um as far as I know and as far as
science claims the the fetus inside of
the womb is a human being well how are
we defined that I find it by the way I'm
very delicious at Euro now obviously
sort of referencing science I believe
this is right the people who have well
will do climate change another day we'll
have someone else on the air to talk
about that but um what why are you
define that as a human being because you
use the word fetus right human being
separately and then you use them
interchangeably a fetus is not yet a
human being I'm wondering then what you
think it is what what species is it is
it like canine or this is that this is a
thing that people on the right do and
they say oh the fetus doesn't turn into
a dog it doesn't turn into a sea otter
you know whatever it is that's not what
I'm saying what I'm saying is that we
put different value in different stages
of human life all the time you know it's
not yet even I would say the same thing
if it's a whale a fetus in a whale is
not yet a whale it's a potential whale
this is effectively a zygote could be
seen as a parasite by scientific
definition to use the people who you
love to give credibility but it's not
yet a human being why do you think that
it is a human being on par with
requiring the rights that are seen from
someone like you or myself
yeah I think I think with you because
DNA is already the DNA of that fetus
embryos I go whatever you want to call
it is human DNA and it's not anything
else it can't ever be anything else
so as DNA what defines a human none by
your definition I mean yeah science
defines it that way yeah so if I do that
and I scrape off some dead skin cells
that's I mean that's DNA is that is that
like mass genocide right died according
to the world according to Abby Johnson
because your skin cells are not living
human beings
or the potential living human beings
just like a fetus right that's where we
get into this ground if everyone has a
line apparently yours is it skin cells
and mine is that mine is that you know a
woman being forced to carry a pregnancy
could you send me an article Skylar
about I'd be interested about any sort
of research where skin cells have been
turned into a human being okay so this
brings us onto the further point so it's
for you it's the potential to be a human
being that makes one a human being
no it just is a human being okay but
then we get back into this wordplay it's
not human being yet its potential to be
a human being so I want to understand I
mean because right now let's let's let's
deal with the actual human being who's
there the mother right why are you so
vehement in denying the choice to the
mother who is living who is sentient who
has a whole lifetime of experiences
memories emotions why are you giving the
right-of-way to a potential human being
so is for you sentience that's what
defines a human being well I think it's
a part of it yeah
does that not for you know why not well
I mean would you say that someone who's
in a vegetative state is not a human
being if they're not sentient
well they do use your sort of
metaphysics they have the potential to
come back from that right they were a
human being already before that
vegetative state presumably so then what
are they while they're in the vegetative
state they're in flux yeah they're in
flux but I would be okay with pulling
the you know I can go back to Terri
Schiavo that's a whole different topic
about euthanasia I think that people
should have the right to do that
especially if they're seriously causing
harm to those around them who are being
forced to support someone who no longer
has the ability to take care of themself
so I think that my point of view there
is remarkably consistent okay well I I
find
to be completely unscientific Schuyler
actually and I mean I gotta tell you
that
embryology textbooks would disagree with
you physicians would disagree with you
and and actually I think that the
pro-choice movement would have a lot
more credibility if they would just come
out and admit that abortion is
terminating a human being in fact you
know dr. LeRoy Carhart who is a very
infamous abortion doctor he just
recently said in an interview with the
BBC that he is killing a baby when he
performs abortions and as terrible as as
we might think that is is as pro-lifers
i at least have some sort of respect for
him for admitting what he's doing
so you said physicians would disagree
with me are these the physicians who
fired you on ceremoniously from Planned
Parenthood oh I was a fired no I wanted
to tell the story behind that sure yeah
I ended up leaving Planned Parenthood on
my own free will
after witnessing well a few things
actually one being free will seems
important to you yeah something that we
can get circle back to that free will is
also them that makes a human but yes go
back to your terminate termination there
at yeah so I was told to double the
abortion quota that we had at Planned
Parenthood mm-hmm the number of
abortions that we had to sell to limit
and ultimately though I ended up leaving
after witnessing a live ultrasound
guided abortion where I saw a 13 week
old fetus attempting to move away from
the abortion instruments and I knew then
that that life did exist in the womb and
that I was on the wrong side of this
debate right so that's when you left and
had a lucrative
book deal and film deal but that's the
topic for another day um you talk about
free will obviously um why does that
matter if that if all that makes up a
human being is its DNA I guess my
question here is if you say that it's a
human being are you saying then that
abortion is in fact like the people with
the signs and the chopped up baby parts
do you believe that abortion is murder
well I think right now with murders
illegal turn so I don't think that we
can define abortion as murder right now
because abortion unfortunately is legal
in the United States however the hope
then for us as pro lifers is that we
would make abortion illegal and
therefore abortion would be seen as
murder if abortion were to be illegal
and so what would you do at that point
would you jail every woman who's
exercised their choice to terminate a
pregnancy you mean retroactively Lee
yeah no in fact that's against the
Constitution so we're not allowed to do
that and actually I I'm not a person who
says oh well if abortion becomes illegal
then we throw women who have abortions
in prison I think that we have to look
at intent most women do not go into
abortion clinics with the intent of
maliciously killed you know we live in
time society and pressures around these
women are causing them to feel like they
have no other choice but to have
abortions so we definitely have to look
at intent in those situations because
women don't have abortions alone there's
many different women there's many
different players in a woman's decision
to have an abortion yeah but I mean
that's in any other scenario right
intent might affect the severity the
degree of the murder
but it seems to me that if you're saying
you make it illegal women would have to
go to prison because there's nowhere
else in the current legal system that
I'm aware of maybe you can correct me
with some references to science here or
assume you're legal scholar as well
where people it's it's reduced to
manslaughter you know even if someone
didn't intend to so I don't I can't
think of anywhere else where someone who
would be involved in the decision to
abort a baby where they wouldn't be
legally liable it seems to me that if
you do that women would have to be
jailed for this crime I don't think they
have to be jailed I think for me I think
that that women are many women are truly
victims of our current society and the
culture of death that we live in and so
I think that you have to look at
different situations I think that you
know we could be talking about an issue
of manslaughter over being charged with
murder but you know we don't know how
that's gonna all shake out we haven't
even overturned roe v wade yet so but it
what do you say yet is that is that your
goal you say yet is that what yeah
really so you would want to overturn
something from what I understand you're
more conservative but you would want to
overturn what is recognized as a
constitutional right to abortion in Roe
V way yeah what's to stop people from
turning over the firt that you know
right to free speech or to bear arms at
that point if we're just taking away
rides sometime I don't think that we
should ever have a right sentence you
force ourselves upon another human being
and take their life so if that's a
constitutional right and honestly
abortions not really a constitutional
right it was sort of looped in under the
right of privacy but the Constitution
doesn't say anywhere that a woman has a
right to have an abortion oh I don't
know about that I'm often looks at up
afterward but uh Louis is there any
scenario in which you believe that
abortion our termination of a pregnancy
would be permissible would you make any
exceptions no
not even I mean Moses you're pretty
radical done in that point of view
because even a lot of people on the
right wing would make exceptions for you
know rape incest and health of the
mother of course Pacino makes up a large
portion of abortions performed you
wouldn't have any exceptions for those
no in fact the overwhelming majority
about 97% of abortions take place
because of convenience so only about 3%
of women who have abortions claim that
they're having an abortion because of
there are life or health and because of
rape or incest in fact the majority of
women who do can see from rape actually
choose to parent their children a very
small percentage actually choose
abortion
well yeah but see they make that choice
you would remove that choice so if a
woman is let's say raped let's say in a
place like West Virginia or Oklahoma you
know red states do you think you would
force that woman that girl to carry a
rapist baby I'm not forcing her to do
anything but I'm just simply saying you
shouldn't have a right to kill another
human being well you are forcing her to
carry that rapist baby if you're not
allowing her to have an abortion you're
forcing her to carry the child I'm not
forcing her so she could be only I mean
the only act of force that's been
carried out upon her is the actual raid
and I don't believe that one act of
violence should then be returned with
another act of violence which is exactly
what abortion is so what would you do
what would you say to someone who's a
victim of incestuous rape who wants to
terminate the pregnancy
your your since you're against it no one
else can have the right to freedom of
choice um so what would you say that
person she's sitting right here right in
front of you right now but you know she
had the courtesy to turn off her iphone
she's sitting right there but would you
tell her sorry sorry you were raped by
your you know by your goony brother but
this we overturn roe v wade that doesn't
seem compassionate
for someone who seems to care about life
what about the life of the mother yeah I
hear that Skyler I do but here's the
thing there are actually studies that
have been done on this and what they
have found is that women who conceive
from rape actually fare better far
better emotionally if they choose to
place the child for adoption or choose
to parent so as a person who considers
herself pro-woman
and really someone who could have fooled
now use women and speaks up for women I
can't eat good conscience tell a woman
that it's in her best interest to have
an abortion not when all the data out
there says that by her having an
abortion she will not do well
emotionally she will suffer great trauma
and that she will essentially be having
to heal from yet another traumatic
incident in her life so I mean if I'm a
person who says I'm really gonna support
women I don't want to support them being
re-traumatized by abortion after
something as heinous as rape well I can
both agree it's heinous so if you're
saying that the the outcomes are better
for women who are raped to carry the
child sounds to me like my stop rape
they're doing they're doing better by
your logic right they're doing better if
they're right to have babies what's
what's the difference well I don't think
they're doing better than women who
haven't been raped oh you're just and
they're doing better than women who've
been raped in have abortions performed
yes yeah I don't know I'd be curious to
see that data here's something that's
important to me what's the difference
for example let's do a thought exercise
this baby
all right this fetus is I goat is
entirely dependent on the mother right
there's no possible chance at viability
so what's the difference between let's
say a mother not properly caring for the
baby
not properly let's say maybe she's
malnourished or she doesn't take
prenatal vitamins right is that
considered at that point would that be
considered murder in your eyes because
the idea here is listen this baby is
completely dependent on the mother it's
not a viable human being outside of the
womb so again it comes to this idea of
forcing women to take care of
effectively what is a parasite I think
we have to look at it a different way I
think we want women to take care of
themselves so if a woman is malnourished
then we need to look at what's happening
in her life because that's not only
affecting the life of her baby but
that's affecting her life so I'm not
really sure even in the end what that
has to do with abortion because if a
woman is not eating if she's starving to
death then we want to make sure that
we're taking care of her and that will
in turn take care of her child
right but the point years we're kind of
getting to the argument of viability but
baby is not viable without the mother so
where do we where does not never mind
probably called and I can tell you you
can't live without me either
well he can breathe on his own right he
has of course needs to be cared for
that's difference from there's a
difference being that an actual
viability the ability to survive merely
outside of the womb basic primary
functions
you know central nervous system the
ability to breathe developed lungs
that's not the case with these zygotes
to what you're referring is that not
enter into the equation and all
viability to define a human being or at
least as it relates to rights I mean the
mother who is viable should her rights
not matter at that point even though
she's a viable human being on her own
she has to take care of an unviable
human being because avi Johnson says so
well I mean viability is not really that
important to me I mean it either is a
innocent human life
or it's not and whether it's viable or
not I mean that's sort of a moot point
we have a responsibility to take care of
humans that are in our care I have a
responsibility to take care of my eight
children I have a responsibility to care
for my children when they are in the
womb and viability really is such a it's
so subjective because as medical science
continues to advance viability the weeks
that determine viability continue to
decrease so you know even thirty years
ago a baby that was born at 30 weeks
gestation would have a very difficult
time surviving at 30 weeks now we've got
babies being born alive at 21 22 weeks
that are surviving outside of the limb
so we can't really dictate what's moral
or immoral based on medical science that
continues to advance well I do think it
has somewhat of an effect let me let's
do another thought experiment here let's
say there were a fire at a fertility
clinic right you could rescue a kid in
the waiting room or a bunch of test-tube
embryos so who would you rescue the test
tubes or would you rescue the child
first
well these sort of hypothetical
situations are really cute and they're I
don't think you I don't they're not
meant to do anything I was trying to
what are you saying that an emotional
reaction I get that but all I got you
know attention I get that you're not
answering the question so you would save
that you would save the the tubes before
the job listen take a puff on your wait
listen to me
we're not rescuing sound like what I'm
hearing but I will yeah sure it's not
the same as directly killing them okay
so there's really a false equivalence
there so here's here's a here's a
thought experiment for you Skyler so
let's say there was a fire
and you had to choose between saving
your own child which I doubt you have
but let's pretend that you do and saving
a black child that's not yours which one
would you say well first off you know
what they say about assumptions makes an
ass out of you yeah me but in this case
just you because I would save the black
child first listen how can you solve it
I've been answering questions more than
I can say for him of course you would
save your own child first that's what we
are innately created to do to protect
our own children to protect those that
we love so of course we're going to do
that that's not wrong but that doesn't
make you a racist for not saving the
black child that's it or no I'm not a
racist because I saved the black child
when your episode okay no sir I would
say if I would save all the black
children frankly before I got down the
line to my kid yeah but I don't want to
have kids because listen I think we
already have a climate that's too
unstable as it stands right now so but I
understand you have like what you like
you have 12 or 15 kids thank you breeder
breeder central right here Yeah right so
make it my carbon footprint is like whoa
and you think that's responsible just
because some some some guy in a foot in
it elites it says that you can't use a
Jimmy hat oh I don't like using oh well
that's no no I'm not I don't want to go
into your personal preferences I don't
know I need to know if there's like some
kind of a weird Vietnamese hammock in
your closet somewhere though in my
experience the people who tend to be the
most reserved conservative who want to
preserve family values have great yeah
they do
oh so you're acknowledging them yeah so
maybe all this is really just yeah maybe
all this is just stemming from the fact
that you personally want to justify your
preferences your freakishness as you're
saying and maybe it's not really rooted
in science as you were trying to say
earlier
I would solder it inside well listen I
would save all the black children first
so I don't know I mean I think that's
that's more about you and it says about
me honestly
Louis's so you consider yourself under
her demonic ur a lot right pro-life
because they wanted as well I'm pro-life
I'm not pro death so are you pro-life
after the baby's born or just before
this is something I would have a problem
with the pro-life do you want to think
that we're prober yeah well look after
the babies board do you support things
like socialized health care how about
education about free nannying how about
paternity leave and maternity leave and
z turna t leave
what do you support after the baby's
born or is it just hey listen we made
sure that the mom didn't have a choice
while you were you know behind the birth
canal but now you're on your own yeah no
I'm definitely pro-life before and after
birth so I I do support women and their
their children we have in fact the
probably feel like the pro-life
movements are probably we're probably
the largest organization helping the
largest group of people helping children
who are born and I mean we pregnancy
centers we're providing care for many
women and children we have maternity
homes that provide housing we have
centers that provide resources diapers
and things like that you know you won't
ever walk into a Planned Parenthood and
find a store for moms where they can get
diapers so I'm sort of wondering like
why it is that if they say they they are
for women making choices why they don't
help support women who make a choice for
life I think they have the choice to not
turn into pregnancy but then they're
infringing on another woman's choice to
go into a Planned Parenthood you know
and seek the the assistance of a
professional the medical professional
versus now a volunteer army who hand out
free diapers from the back of a news van
a news fan you know they'd seen these
pro-life vans that go around and they do
these free ultrasounds for women I mean
I certainly wouldn't put that on par
with the ability of a doctor and ob/gyn
a Planned Parenthood to actually provide
women's health services you know I've
written not just termination of
pregnancy by the way that's a small
portion of Planned Parenthood's proceeds
as you well know and that's why I think
these organizations are very important
and the pro-life community is crippling
women's health care in general which
again would let me suggest and
anti-choice know yeah you know that
would be true if it were actually OB
gens that were providing care for women
inside of Planned Parenthood but they're
not in fact I was the director of a
Planned Parenthood and I'm not a nurse
or a doctor or anything I mean I don't
mind a medical assistant any sort of
medical credential but I was running the
holding place so remember that's why you
were fired no no no wasn't fired but you
know it's interesting because that is a
lie a myth that goes around about
Planned Parenthood that they have all of
this high-quality health care and the
bottom line is that the only thing that
they provide that would be difficult for
a woman to receive at another health
care facility with actually better care
would be abortion I mean you can get a
woman can get a pap smear anywhere she
wants and it's not just pap smear
abortion contraceptives mammograms these
are secrets what do you think no
mammograms
there's no point Parenthood in the
country has a mammogram machine yes
mammograms I do have mammogram machines
no no we actually did a FOIA request
Freedom of Information Act not sure if
you're familiar with that you have to
look it up but there's we actually did a
FOIA request because in order to run a
mammogram machine you have to have a
license to run that machine so we looked
in every state who has licenses for
these mammogram machines and
shockingly are not so shockingly plant
heron it doesn't have any well they can
refer you to a place that does its very
least sure yeah I can refer somebody to
a place that does know you would need to
be a medical professional or for some no
no actually the law states that you
don't have to receive a referral from a
medical professional to get a mammogram
oh I just I find this hard to believe I
find this hard to believe that everybody
else you know we know this that we've
had people talking about obviously
Planned Parenthood and the women's
health that they provide including
mammograms and Abby Johnson has figured
something out that everybody else must I
don't think everybody else misses I mean
in fact Cecile Richards the prep the
former president Planned Parenthood had
to admit in congressional testimony that
they don't provide mammograms so I
actually I feel like maybe you just
missed it no I don't think that I've
missed anything at all you know I think
that you framed us you know you're very
clever with us you framed it and that
you just don't think a woman has a right
to assuming that someone goes on was
your idea that mere DNA defines human
being you've sort of created this
dynamic of a woman doesn't have a right
to terminate another person's life but
the fact is this life is dependent on
that woman right was sort of covered
viability this is very similar to
forcing a woman to donate a kidney or
forcing a woman to take care of another
human being that she didn't sign up to
take care of there isn't any kind of a
contract that's so you are forcing that
woman to take probe to take proactive
actions in caring for another human
being right so either way you say once
you can't proactively kill him in vain
well I'm saying you can't proactively
force a woman to give her plasma and her
her life force to another human being
why do you feel comfortable forcing a
woman to do that yeah I like the kidney
analogy that's good I don't I don't
think that it's I don't think you're
quite there with it because I think the
reality be if someone chose to donate a
kidney and then the comparison that
you're trying to make would be then if
they said
nevermind I'm gonna take my kidney back
because every time that a person engages
in sexual activity
aside from rape you are making the
conscious decision to embark upon
possible consequences that could mean
creating life so if you're not okay with
that
I mean there really is a simple solution
I mean it's your action that led to the
creation of a human being so if you
don't want to be held responsible for
that action then don't commit that
action so you would support then free
subsidized birth control and
contraceptives for everyone out there
then to reduce the amount of unwanted
pregnancies well-used interesting that
you bring that up because when I first
left Planned Parenthood I remember
thinking that was the answer but you
know when you look at the Guttmacher
Institute which is essentially Planned
Parenthood's research arm they actually
shown that 54% of women who get
abortions were using contraception at
the time that they got pregnant so
clearly the answer isn't just simply
birth control because I mean if you look
at what this means is if you look into a
waiting room an abortion clinic waiting
room more than half of those women were
contracepting and they're they're
pregnant and waiting to get an abortion
so I'm not sure that contraception is
actually the solution I think that we
need I mean we really need to be talking
to people about self control we need to
educate people about their bodies but I
just don't think that birth control is
actually this this solution that
everybody wants it to be it's a
multi-pronged approach and that same
token I could say oh listen you know
that means that over that close to half
of those people weren't using
contraception because of a lack of
quality education because of the
religious rights abstinence only
education I don't understand how you
don't want abortions but you don't want
to take all these actions that would
reduce the abortions free contraceptives
education that let people know about how
to use contraceptives properly it seems
like the only problem you have is when
it comes to abortion you seem more
passionate about limiting choice of
women than actually helping them prevent
unwanted pregnancies yeah I'm super
passionate about not killing innocent
human beings that's true so then why
wouldn't you be as passionate about
preventing that scenario from even
occurring it seems to me that that's
something a lot of people on the right
don't it's it's it's not really um I
don't know how you justify that well as
I just told you birth control is not the
solution to this problem as Planned
Parenthood in the group marker Institute
have already shown us I think that we do
need better education I would definitely
agree with that but you know telling a
woman well the problem is yours don't
get pregnant here's some birth control
is really not what we should be telling
women that's really shirking it's
allowing men to Circular responsibility
that they have and I just don't really
think that that's something that we want
to promote isn't I mean well I first of
all you know as a man I mean I don't
think that men should be involved in
this decision at all right penis no
opinion yeah so you know so you don't
support roe v wade in oh no I do yeah
okay but you know that all the justices
that decided Roe we're we're men right I
do see your point yeah I see your point
with the wordplay there but I'm talking
about the man involved in the action of
trading that that fetus that zygote once
it's no woman's body right she's the
incubator the guy has nothing to do with
it so no penis no contribution to that
life I mean albeit sometimes small and a
short contribution but there was a
contribution made yeah but now the
contribution is out of
and some woman's I just saying of only
women should have an opinion on this
issue I don't think it's right for men
to step in and tell them what she can do
with her body I'm gonna seems to me I
don't know why you would be against that
as a woman that doesn't mean I
understand you think that a man should
be able to tell you what you can do with
your body or not that's weird I think
that fertility is all because I saw your
skype caught out at the last second what
was that I said I believe that that
fertility should be shared between a
woman and a man because of science I
can't create human life on my own well
you can create life now without men
because of to go back to your point
earlier medical advancements and I think
that's probably why we're it's probably
what we're headed considering how toxic
um I'm willing to admit this that's the
same reason I would save a black child
before my own child
white people and men have contributed a
very toxic culture to this entire
discussion so yeah I think hopefully
hopefully we can be progressive enough
that that's where we're headed final
question here we do have to get going
it's Abby Johnson unplanned film.com is
available now and I know with this film
you focus a lot on sort of ultra late
term abortions because it scares people
a lot but it's less than 1% of abortions
do you think that's very misleading or
dishonest from the fact is the vast
majority of abortions occur at a point
where most people would support it well
I mean that's true late term abortion is
a small percentage it ends up being
around anywhere between 15 and 18,000
abortions a year that are taking place
in in the later weeks of pregnancy which
is still a lot I mean 15 18,000 late
term babies being killed I mean that
that's a lot and to your point
these babies are viable could live
outside of the womb which I mean right
now that's well I think that's why you
use them as an example because you think
it's more effective but it's it's a it's
a red herring but for me I mean actually
my story is
about an abortion that took place in 13
weeks in the first trimester so I mean
in a way Schuyler I would agree with you
because I don't think that I don't think
that the pro-life movement should be
specifically saying oh well late term
abortion is ultra heinous because
realistically first trimester abortion
is is just as heinous I mean if we as
pro lifers believe that life is life
then in the end it really doesn't matter
what week that child's life is
terminated it's all wrong
so final question once we take the
totality of abortions of terminated
pregnancies let's say you had your way
and these hadn't been performed right
and let's assume that women didn't go
and get back alley abortions which was
what they would do but let's assume
that's not the case
who takes care of these millions of
babies of unwanted babies from this
scenario I mean you're talking millions
of people at this point into the
population you don't have people to care
for them yeah that's interesting
actually we passed a law in Texas a few
years ago that required teenagers to
have parental consent before they could
get an abortion and we you know we
didn't really know what they what's not
sound very proud of that
miss Pol Pot yeah super super proud and
you know we were trying to look at the
numbers later what we found was that not
only we knew that the number of
abortions would decrease but what we
were surprised at is that the actual
number of teen pregnancies in the state
decreased and I think one of the reasons
was because these these girls knew that
they were not going to have the easy
solution of abortion if they got caught
and they ended up getting pregnant so
these girls ended up making more
responsible decisions so I think that we
we sort of I think it's sort of a
multi-pronged approach here that when
you pass laws it also restricts behavior
it's not just the consequence of that
behavior but I think it causes people to
look and to say well I don't have this
option so maybe I won't participate in
this action you can fear no control you
know take personal responsibility for
their actions that charan know you in
this way okay I'll let you finish and
then and then I would like to hear your
closing thoughts because we do have to
get going but yes continue but then also
I mean yeah I mean I'm sure that there
would be women who would go and and have
dangerous you know dangerous abortions
but that's not a reason to keep
something legal
I mean drinking and driving is illegal
and people still continue to drink and
drive we're not going to say well
because some people do it we're going to
allow drinking and driving to be legal
and then Erich Mielke family waiting to
adopt children and a lot of adoption
agencies have actually had to close in
the past few years because they have so
many families waiting but no babies to
actually adopt out alright well that's
the whole discussion for another day so
in closing here I want to give you the
floor on planned film.com if you're
still interested in that what is what
would you want people to most know about
yourself or about the pro-life movement
your final case I guess does it work
sure so if people want to know more
about me they can go to Abby Johnson or
RG a BBY Johnson or G if they want to
know more about the film they can go to
see unplanned comm you can purchase the
film there you can also purchase the
digital download it is streaming on
Amazon and you know I just want people
to be encouraged we've had huge
victories over the past few days Planned
Parenthood was just in
in a recent verdict they were required
to pay three million dollars to a former
one of their former employees one of
their former directors because they were
doing a lot of really terrible things
she exposed and so that's come out in
the media that we've released that
yesterday also Trump just recently took
Planned Parenthood out of the title ten
funding program we're seeing a decrease
in abortion rates across the country so
you know good things are happening now
it's not the time to let our guard down
we need to keep moving forward so there
you go folks
title ten Donald Trump defunding women's
the biggest women's health care provider
in the United States and they've been
forced to pay somebody out a disgruntled
employee Abby Johnson sees as victories
very reminiscent of when they strolled
on in through Poland in the 1940s Abby
Johnson thank you for taking the time I
appreciate it and now see if people are
convinced yeah thanks Jason
all right thanks this has been devil's
advocate I'm your host skeleton and I'll
see you I'll see you next time know how
much longer I can do this is what just
see videos of teaching if you like this
video you should be ashamed of yourself
and don't subscribe or hit the
notification bell because this isn't my
channel it's just a loaner for a little
bit and I don't like that I have to do
this but I want to reach more people so
you know find me elsewhere but don't
don't have anything to do with this
channel they've on bro